le samedi 23 mai à 10h30 la ville de
montigny le bretonneux sera la première
commune de saint quentin en yvelines a
installé son conseil municipal
si le préfet des yvelines l'autorisent
il pourrait se dérouler à la grange de
la ferme du manet en présence du public
nous sommes en train d'organiser
effectivement les choses pour que les
chaque personne puisse avoir ses quatre
mètres carrés tels que telles qu'elles
sont demandées par par l'état nous avons
la capacité
étant donnée la superficie de la salle
de la grange d'accueillir aussi un petit
peu de public donc nous en avons fait la
demande au préfet nous attendons sur
tours et si le préfet elle accepte tant
mieux nous pourrons accueillir un petit
peu de public
sinon nous l'organiserons à huis clos et
dans ce cas là nous nous sommes en train
de regarder pour assurer une
retransmission de la du conseil pour que
les terres bien sûr son caractère public
à maurepas le nouveau conseil municipal
sera mise en place également le samedi
23 mai à 15 heures pour respecter les
règles de distanciation il se déroulera
au gymnase de la malle me donne
l'installation du conseil qui sera
également déplacé à coignières un
conseil à huis clos le lundi 25 mai à
19h45 à la maison de voisinage cette
durée sera volontairement plus courte en
raison des règles sanitaires à la nation
l'élection du maire tout d'abord avec la
ça va être le pr je dirais la première
délibération à l'élection du maire
ensuite il ya la détermination du nombre
d'adjoints
donc on va rester sur ce que l'on avait
fait précédemment c'est à dire huit
adjoints et le nombre aussi de
conseiller délégué donc nous en aurons 3
ensuite y'a l'élection des adjoints et
puis ensuite il ya la délégation des
pouvoirs aubert aussi que l'on va pas
très lors de ce conseil et puis enfin
l'indemnité des élus à elancourt
l'installation du nouveau conseil
municipal se déroulera le mercredi 27
mai l'heure et le lieu sont encore à
définir
enfin magny les hameaux le conseil se
déroulera à huis clos le jeudi 28 mai à
19 heures salle de festivités au trait
d'union
au total cinq communes saint quentinois
sont concernés par ces installations de
conseils municipaux dans les yvelines 2
115 communes ont désigné leur mère au
premier tour en mars dernier
[Applaudissements]